and low guys were back here at the
supper suite in Austin for South by
Southwest and I am really thrilled to be
sitting here on behalf of the wonderful
hint water because without sponsors like
them we wouldn't be talking about movies
like darlin today so first off
congratulations
welcome to the studio thank you for
giving us your time today thank you for
having so just to start here because a
lot of our viewers might not know what
this movie is does anybody feel like
giving a brief synopsis and also maybe
explaining the connection to the movie
the woman also which I'm sure they don't
use the writer the director and the star
to tell you further Thank You Bryan
hello hello everyone so darlin is a
standalone sequel to the woman the woman
was actually a sequel to offspring and
Andrew will actually be the better
person to talk about the way the
franchise has come together but for my
part I wrote and directed darling as as
a sequel to the woman that can stand
alone where you haven't seen the woman
you find to watch darlin it's about a
feral teenage girl being indoctrinated
into the Catholic Church and in his
attempt to civilize her good luck with
that one go was it always a priority to
make it a standalone because we're also
in an industry right now where
everything has to be a franchise or a
cinematic universe and you just have to
build and build and build and so you
know everything in anything and it's so
refreshing to see something that I could
say go see that and then explore the
first two movies that came before it
yeah it's totally true though too you
can experience these films completely
out of order and they all kind of work
together it doesn't matter which course
you're gonna have first although I have
to say I think darlin would be a pretty
delicious entree just saying it's a
perfect way to put it I'm curious for
the three of you now what was it like
seeing the script for the first time was
there any intimidation or apprehension
here yes I loved it I mean it's a
brilliant script probably on a rope on
straight away I was like this character
god I would love to sink my teeth in
this a lot literally
hardly I can't even begin to imagine all
the puns that have come up while talking
about this movie and I'm enjoying it's
been about a month of doing this
non-stop so I read the script I thought
god this is a phenomenal script it's so
interesting so deep so multi-layered but
also I jumped at the opportunity because
it's something I've kind of character
I've never had the opportunity to play
before I was quite quite thrilled with
the with the result I think you did an
amazing job thank you
yeah Brian's used to playing more
sympathetic characters than the one we
ended up casting him in here but but no
Jane has more to say he's like he made
it Joey obviously you can tell it was
just a lot of fun even though you know
there was some thrilling her moments it
was still a lot of fun to shoot and I
loved like the minute I read the script
I loved it it was just so intelligent
and layered and refreshing and there's
so much to it
okay I can't do spoiler things right I
have to be vague don't I that's got it's
got a bit of everything is all I'm
trying to say and it's and it takes you
by surprise because each element is as
strong as the other and you come away
from it feeling really good and
empowered and excited for where it's
gonna go next so I watching the film the
first time where I I started laughing
hysterically and I because you know it's
scene and I almost stopped myself like
no it's gonna get serious and scary soon
but I no no no go with the laughter and
I went with it all of a sudden zip right
back you got me right back it was like
it was like a punch you you're you're
taking on a complete journey with this
you really don't know what's gonna
happen or what's around the corner
because it's so out there it's such a
new kind of world that we're there
explore we're exploring wit and also
with the church you know that aspect too
but it was a fun roller coaster ride
don't you think beautifully shot the the
makeup effects are quite intense but
also the physicality of these roles too
so for the two of you I mean what kind
of physical training I guess do you have
to do because if you like watching a
performance like yours in particular
someone might not think about how taxing
that could be on the body we didn't
really do too much training it actually
just took a lot of running around on set
in my hotel room growling at myself and
just being really free I've watched the
woman so many times and just stole a lot
of what Pollyanna do because she's so
clever and then used it darlin fully
prepared locked and loaded for this role
she was incredibly physical in the
performance that she gave in the
audition and then she gave a tender
terrified heartfelt completely focused
performance in in the other scene that
we asked her to do which was a more
dramatic scene yeah Lauren canny is an
incredible talent and you will be seeing
it's easy happening before she even came
in and I know that she went deep into
the characters I watched a lot of thing
animals on YouTube in the wild
like just watched hours of like lions
and tigers and bears process it was rape
it was great is the horror genre it's
it's we do we had so much fun shooting
it you know it was under crazy
circumstances and conditions and I think
it all stems from you know Pollyanna and
and our producer and and setting this
tone and everyone had had a great time
we really did even though their moments
that were very intense and very you know
difficult during the shooting I didn't
know if we were gonna have as good of a
time because it is a heavy film with a
lot of stuff going on but um and I
thought like maybe our scenes were gonna
be quite difficult but like look at you
you're just the crack so we just you
couldn't different vibe from your
character incredible to do acting really
I love hearing about first-time feature
Directors cuz I am fascinated by
somebody who wants to take the plunge
because it's not easy getting that off
the ground so I'm curious what morning
did you wake up and say like I need to
do this and why this particular story to
make your feature directorial debut
thank you you know I feel like I've been
preparing this for this for a long time
I was directing theater and producing
theater before and I'd made this short
film which was a 35 minutes short which
was basically the first act of a feature
that I wrote and Andrew came to me
asking if I'd like to direct this
feature because I've been in the
previous one and and he had faith in my
work we'd worked together on various
things before and he'd seen me go what
about this what about this enough times
to go I think you should probably be
directing maybe not on my movie maybe
like on your own because I'll you know
as always when we were working together
hysterectomy as actor we were I was
always asking lots of questions and
getting involved like on every film that
you know and TV show that I've done I'm
trying to watch as much as possible and
so it was really I was preparing for
this and then the the really great call
came and it came together quite quite
beautifully is there anybody else that's
influenced you along the way also
because hearing about the great vibe
that you created on this set was there
any other set in your past that you've
been on that you said I want my movie to
feel like this I think it's um I think
it's probably coming from an actor's
perspective knowing what it's like out
there in there in your own head you know
in the world of what we do
but I think also at just my mother kind
of named me right you know the positive
and so you know it's just it just felt
it just feels like you want to make you
want everyone to be the best that they
can be you want everybody want to
support people and you also want to
drive them forward to do you know to go
the extra mile and and we had a great
you know we had a great cast and crew
around us and Andrew put together a
great team
I mean honestly Pollyanna is one of
these people that has no fear and so she
steps into the character and then she's
directing all of a sudden and then she's
back in characters so it's one of the
most surreal things because she she's
the woman so you don't want to piss her
off if you're I wish we had behind the
scenes for you directing in full costume
it was a real on the monitor this sounds
glorious you never ask someone to do
something you wouldn't do you know you
you guys were so entrenched and and and
and committed so I mean like what
there's nothing we wouldn't you know
Brian was like you know this is really
intense a long day are we gonna you know
get going and shoot and I said Brian
it's gonna be great we're gonna get it
done and you were so cool and you came
and hung out with us for that long long
day and it was a hundred and thirty two
hour day but it was incredible Brian is
the bat play nice with others and have a
good time yeah Instagram plays nice with
others it makes me feel better to hear
that you guys had such a good time
making this movie because so much of it
is so stressful to watch also even from
a producing perspective to just like
with the nature of like certain violent
acts that happen in it it feels like it
has a pretty wide scope and then all the
hair and makeup in the physicality that
goes into it it's it's a lot for a first
feature it's very impressive
thank you thank you yeah it was quite an
undertaking before we have to wrap the
script good for you
people need producers like that we have
a couple of random questions rapid-fire
questions that we want to quickly ask
you guys super fun super light stuff
first up what TV show would you love to
guest star on killing gave me two ways
hi myself okay what movie do you quote
the most Auntie Mame life's a banquet
and most poor sons of [ __ ] are
starving to death
I probably quote Breakfast at Tiffany's
a fair amount because I just love to do
Audrey Hepburn and oh god i frozen go
for it probably The Princess Bride my
name is Inigo Montoya you killed my
father prepare to die I think that's
pretty woman there's nothing wrong with
that yes do you guys collect anything
good friends lots of movies and
incredibly amazing talented artists in a
box as a producer chef art and bad
habits since I've moved to LA cactuses
and I like your good friends cheers
thank you I don't well I'll take good
friends and just run with that and
something to do a food I'm sure I do
like just like a collection of great
restaurants that I go to everywhere I'll
try my popular cufflinks I really do
collect playing cards too I find them in
the street and it's kind of fun because
once you hear that you'll find them too
seriously it's good thing there's like a
new horror movie idea in that I don't
know what it is but I want to see it
what is the worst job you've ever had I
was the mascot for Lionel play world
before it became toys arise and it was
like a six-foot kangaroo costume that
came over to New Orleans from Texas in
the middle of summer it stunk so bad
from Bo from weeks and weeks of body
odor that they finally came up after a
couple hours and said you will pay you
just go home this thing stinks so much
you end and I was horrible
it's a real problem I was a pink duck at
a radio station at my first internship
and I am scarred for life from that
experience was a call center and it was
it was for a cool charity but it was
just that thing of having to go can you
donate this much and they're like oh
well I do I run like 36 miles every year
and I do a sale at my house and can you
give five dollars and then they go yeah
but you know I also did this other
charity stuff on the lot on the side and
I give away all my clothes and I do this
and I do that and then you're like yeah
it was horrible I worked in build-a-bear
for a few months
when I was in school and sometimes I may
have been out the night before and then
had to go and stuff bears for six hours
well talking to very young children and
that was pretty horrific so dangerous
combination it's so great sometimes two
kids are walk right bugs I worked in a
restaurant in LA which is no longer with
the boss was a complete dick and
pretentious wanker and the Kardashians
complained about my service and I got
fired oh that guy from they had that guy
from girls gone wild he'd just been
released from jail and the foot for
making women do things and a lovely man
and then they were sitting for a dinner
with him and he had it he had a new
porno magazine out and they all had it
I'm doing this on TV aren't I nevermind
and and they all had their pepp they're
the porn mag out you know they were all
looking at it and celebrating it and
they didn't listen to the specials and I
waited like I heard mistress until
they're all quiet and they all went up
at me and then I got fired
[Laughter]
so I dare ask if you can top that yeah I
mean you know for me it's just
production being a production a producer
on a lower budget production and having
to deal with a crew member that one time
left a little gift for all of us in the
the bathroom before they left and that
was pretty pretty unbelievable actually
did you do like they did with the Abba
poo and help me out guys
Priscilla Queen of the desert and popped
around your neck for good good
safekeeping I didn't oh I don't know how
to transition to an exit right now but I
hope you enjoy all those stories that
guys keep an eye out for darling thank
you so much for coming in today another
huge congratulations on the movie
congratulations on your first feature as
director thank you guys for watching
this please don't forget to like and
share this interview thank you so much
to the supper suite hint water and all
these wonderful sponsors we have here
for making these happen we will see you
soon with more South by Southwest
interviews